hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
du hast dir den Rotweinkuchen gekauft
also die Backmischung und ich zeige dir
heute ganz einfach wie du ihn
zubereitest außer meiner Backmischung in
der eine Backmischung drin ist eine
Glasur und Zuckerstreusel brauchst du
nämlich nur diese drei Zutaten ich habe
hier weiche Butter 3 Eier und etwas
Flüssigkeit bei der Flüssigkeit kannst
du einfach entscheiden nimmst du Rotwein
willst du Rotweinkuchen nimmst du
Traubensaft wird zum traubensaftkuchen
theoretisch kannst du auch Kaffee oder
andere Flüssigkeiten nehmen denn damit
koordinierst du auch so ein bisschen den
Geschmack aber der Kuchen an sich ist
ein richtig schöner zarter saftiger
richtig guter Schokoladenkuchen also er
wird dir auf jeden Fall schmecken ich
zeige euch jetzt mal kurz den Inhalt
Backmischung
Glasur
zuckerstreifen
anders als bei beiden rezeptvideos
gibt's einfach keine Reihenfolge ihr
gebt nämlich einfach nur die
Backmischung und die drei Zutaten in
eine Rührschüssel verrührt alles mit dem
Handrührgerät auf niedriger Stufe kurz
bis es verbunden ist und dann 3 Minuten
cremig rühren fertig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt kurz die backform fetten mit
backtrennspray oder Öl
Teig einfüllen und ab in den Ofen
[Musik]
nach dem Backen habe ich den Kuchen
bisschen abkühlen lassen dann
rausgestürzt jetzt ist er komplett
erkaltet die Glasur habe ich jetzt hier
in dem Teller und mit heißem Wasser
übergossen also einfach kochen das
Wasser damit sie schön warm wird seit
fünf Minuten stehen lassen und man kann
ja im Beutel fühlen ob sie schon perfekt
geschmolzen ist Mikrowelle geht übrigens
auch jetzt eine kleine Spitze
wegschneiden
und über den Kuchen laufen lassen gerne
mit einem Pinsel verteilen mit einem
Löffel oder einfach so drüber und dann
mit dem Zuckerstreuseln dekorieren und
die habe ich auch extra für euch
zusammengestellt das ist eine richtig
schöne winterliche Mischung
[Musik]
und so zaubert ihr ganz schnell einen
richtig leckeren Schokoladenkuchen und
ich würde sagen der Held bei
Raumtemperatur oder auch im Kühlschrank
in paar Tage der ist wirklich saftig
sehr zart und ganz weich aber so gut wie
er schmeckt hält er wahrscheinlich nur
einen Tag durch denn man will ihn sofort
vernaschen ich wünsche Euch jedenfalls
ganz viel Spaß beim Nachbacken falls ihr
nachfragt dann teilt gerne eure Fotos
auf Social Media verlinkt mich damit ich
sehen kann wer diesen Kuchen zubereitet
hat und schaut auch gerne die anderen
Backmischungen an denn ich habe ein paar
Sorten für euch kreiert guten Appetit
bis zum nächsten Mal